I wouldn't want a president it's always
criticized and this person that person
that person a person tension do they you
know I'll let just slamming people and
slander and isn't it
I wouldn't want a president like that no
he'll know if my can't stop that way I
will watch that mouth I was so and
they'll ground are you afraid of Donald
Trump winning I'm not afraid of anyone
winning I think the beauty of America is
that if you qualify to be a candidate
that anyone can be a candidate anybody
Donald Trump and the Republican Party
they they don't know the pulse of the
people I think that they're too far
removed you know when you live in the
ivory tower you don't know what's going
on on the ground if he gets elected I'm
moving to Canada I'm just telling you